ASSUME FOR OTHER REGIONS WITHIN
UKRAINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GENERAL
HERTLING.
I APPRECIATE YOU AS ALWAYS.
>>> MEANTIME, A RUSSIAN
BUSINESSMAN HAS NOW BECOME AT
LEAST THE NINTH PROMINENT
EXECUTIVE TO DIE UNDER
MYSTERIOUS CIRCUMSTANCES IN LESS
THAN A YEAR.
CNN'S TOM FOREMAN IS HERE TO
WALK US THROUGH THIS STRING OF
SUSPICIOUS DEATHS.
TOM, WHO IS THE LATEST
BUSINESSMAN TO DIE?
>> Reporter: SUSPICIOUS IS THE
RIGHT WORD.
IN THIS CASE THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF THE CORPORATION FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE FAR EAST
AND THE ARCTIC.
ON SEPTEMBER 10th, REGIONAL
MEDIA REPORTED HE WAS FOUND
DROWNED.
THERE WERE SOME REPORTS ABOUT
POSSIBLE BOATING ACCIDENT BUT
THERE IS MYSTERY AROUND THIS AND
SUSPICION.
HE IS NOT A MEMBER OF EITHER
GASPROM OR LUKE OIL TWO BIG
COMPANIES OUT THERE NOTABLE
BECAUSE SIX OF THE NINE WHO HAVE
DIED IN THESE SUSPICIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE TWO VERY LARGE ENERGY
COMPANIES.
>> SO WHY WOULD EMPLOYEES OF
THESE ENERGY COMPANIES BE
POTENTIALLY TARGETED?
>> WELL, BECAUSE THESE ENERGY
COMPANIES SPOKE UP EARLY ABOUT
PROBLEMS WITH THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
NOTABLY LUKOIL PUT OUT THIS
STATEMENT IN MARCH WE EXPRESS
OUR SINCERE SYMPATHY FOR ALL
VICTIMS AFFECTED BY THIS
TRAGEDY.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT A LASTING
CEASE-FIRE AND SETTLEMENT OF
PROBLEMS THROUGH SERIOUS
NEGOTIATIONS AND DIPLOMACY.
THIS ABSOLUTELY DID NOT MAKE THE
KREMLIN HAPPY.
SO PEOPLE START LOOKING AT THIS
AND SAYING WHAT CAME NEXT?
TWO MONTHS LATER, ALEXANDER
SUBATIN WAS DEAD AFTER VISITING
A SHAMMEN FOR SOME POSSIBLE
TREATMENT.
SEPTEMBER 1st ANOTHER MAN DIES
AFTER REPORTEDLY FALLING FROM A
HOSPITAL WINDOW.
IN BOTH CASES SOME OFFICIAL
ACCOUNTS PARTICULARLY IN THIS
CASE SAYING HE WAS DEALING WITH
SOME KIND OF ISSUES, MAYBE
DEPRESSION AFTER A HEART ATTACK.
BUT WHEN YOU GO BEYOND THIS AND
PUT IT INTO THE BIG PICTURE IT
GETS CONFUSING.
SIX OF THE NINE OF THESE PEOPLE
IN SUSPICIOUS DEATHS TIED TO
THOSE COMPANIES.
LOOK AT THIS, SUSPECTED SUICIDE,
REPORTED STABBING, SUSPECTED
SUICIDE.
REPORTED STABBING.
MURDER-SUICIDE.
FALLING FROM WINDOW.
ALL OF THESE TAKEN TOGETHER HAVE
REALLY RAISED INTEREST AMONG
PEOPLE SAYING IS THIS THE
MACHINATION OF THE KREMLIN?
WE DO NOT KNOW THAT AND IN THE
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCE THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF BUSINESS
PRESSURE OVER THERE AS WELL AND
THERE COULD BE ELEMENTS WITHIN
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY THAT
MIGHT HAVE COME INTO PLAY WI